mein thema an diesem tag ist scholz hat
zu recht versagt olaf scholz wollte sie
karl lauterbach sowieso doch die
allgemeine impfpflicht ist heute in der
herzkammer der demokratie gescheitert es
ist für scholz ein politisches debakel
besonders schlimm am vormittag hatte er
extra seine außenministerin an lena
berger aus brüssel
zurückbeordert damit sie in berlin mit
abstimmen kann der kanzler wusste er
braucht jede stimme und er dachte er
sich wohl im pflicht wichtiger als nato
treffen zum ukraine krieg nun hat er
verloren die allgemeine impfpflicht ab
60 jahren wirklich kommen das muss für
scholz ein herber verlust sein ich finde
zu recht denn die allgemeine impfpflicht
soll auch nicht kommen die ab 60 nicht
wie heute entschieden wird und auch
nicht die ab 18 und ich bin jetzt sehr
gespannt wie meine gäste das sehen herr
bremer bei bild tv als gast zu sein das
hätte mich schon sehr überrascht wenn
scholz nicht gleich wieder passieren die
ohren kriegt und mit ihm die ganze ampel
aber ein bisschen ist ja daran würde
nicht so weit gehen dass er sozusagen
versagt hat für mich zwei institutionen
kein sehr gutes bild abgegeben das ist
einmal die ampelkoalition
die offenkundig bewiesen hat dass sie
keineswegs so stabil ist dass sie in
einer so wichtigen die menschen wirklich
interessieren den berührenden frage wie
ob nur die impfpflicht vielleicht dafür
sorgen kann das ist eine hohe quote
kriegen und damit nicht noch mal wieder
ein corona herbst mit lockdown
ausgangssperren und kontakt verboten
erleben sich offenkundig nicht zu einer
klaren haltung durchringen kann in einem
begriff von freiheit
den ich eher wo du liberalismus nennen
würde aber da kommen wir ja sicherlich
noch drauf zurück ist ja alles dann
verfassungswidrig alle anderen eingriffe
waren es offenbar dann doch nicht also
habe ich meine probleme die fdp hat kein
gutes bild abgegeben die spd nicht klar
und in der tat haben sie recht warum
vblock schön zu einer abstimmung kommt
bei der eigentlich klar war das ist
nicht auf jede einzelne stimme ankam
sondern entweder man hätte eine mehrheit
gehabt oder man hat sie eben nicht
gehabt und mal klar nicht gab
da wäre glaubt die nato konferenz
wichtiger gewesen wenn sie da geblieben
wäre der zweite aber was ich kritisch
anmerken muss für mich hat der bundestag
fordert das parlament hat versagt wenn
man schon die entscheidung über eine so
wichtige frage ins parlament delegiert
was man kritisieren kann aber was
eigentlich auch vorzüge hat dann muss
ich doch davon ausgehen dass die
abgeordneten als volksvertreter wirklich
die interessen des volkes im kopf haben
und nicht in parteitaktische interessen
oder die interessen von minderheiten und
da hätte ich mir nun schon gewünscht hat
jedenfalls in der nacht zu heute die
ampel und die cdu/csu noch mal
aufeinander zugegangen wenn jetzt haben
eine situation dass gar nicht ist obwohl
im prinzip beide vorschläge gar nicht so
weit auseinander waren für mich zeigt
das auch dass die cdu opposition immer
noch nicht richtig in der opposition
angekommen ist immer noch nicht ganz
verwunden hat dass die 16 jahre vorbei
sind dass sie unbedingt opposition um
jeden preis machen will also insofern
würde ich ihre these relativieren also
dass ich gleich mal was dazu
der angriff war also ich kann sagen ich
hätte wahrscheinlich im dezember letzten
jahres die impfpflicht für alle bekommen
alle standen unter dem eindruck der data
variante die kliniken man überlaufen der
impfstoff hat gewirkt es waren
nachweislich wir haben ich habe nicht
nur allgemein sagen ich recherchiert ist
immer noch mal bei meinem eigenen
krankenhauses cook stimmt das was so
erzählt wird und da war ganz klar dass
vieles hat zugenommen schwere patienten
auf der intensivstation und absolute
mehrheit wirklich waren die ungeimpften
und in dieser situation hätte die ampel
ganz viel unterstützung auch aus der
union begründet
nein nein ich wills mit lassen sie mich
weiter ausreden warum ich glaube das hat
sich wirklich geändert deshalb ist der
vorwurf auch nicht gerechtfertigt das
hat sich total geändert durch omikron
allem auch die kliniken schauen sie sich
an alle möglichen die dreifach also
doppelt gebucht hat stecken sich
inzwischen mit micon an japan nein es
hat wirklich da muss ich sagen es gibt
auch keine bundesverfassungsgerichts
entscheidung zur uni kommen und ich bin
mir auch ziemlich sicher dass die andere
ich glaube
ich unmittelbar betroffen ich bin fast
90 ich trage eine maske ich gehe
einkaufen alle tragen masken künftig
tragen sie das nicht mehr wenn also ein
ich bin dem risiko egoistischer
ungeimpfte ausgesetzt die sich auf
kosten der allgemeinheit
praktisch eine sogenannte freiheit
erkaufen ich fühle mich und geschützter
jetzt und die krankheitsverläufe die ich
meiner umgebung habe sind sehr
schwerwiegend die leute es gibt leute
die sehr schwer erkranken und dem
verfassung steht drinnen wir haben die
gesundheit der menschen zwischen zwei
steht drin halle es gibt ja auch alle
unversehrt alonso beide ist in der
verfassung stehen halt alle grundrechte
die betroffen sind und es ist es einige
blogs recht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit die die nicht geimpft
werden vorne unterschätzen sie das nicht
wie stark die das als eingriff empfinden
es gibt es recht der freiheit angst vor
lockdown auch recht auf eingeübten
ausgeübten gewerbebetrieb dass wir
natürlich haben bei den geschäftskunden
es gibt sie wissen doch die sind noch
jurist in der verfassung ist ein
ausgleich zwischen den verschiedenen
grundrissen und wir haben jetzt mit
honeycomb keinen nachweis mehr dass wir
dadurch ist zu einer deutlichen
verbesserung zu deutlich mehr schutz des
sp2 maßen pflicht die wird abgeschafft
das ist eine sehr hochgradige schutz vor
ungefähr halten die red ich mal rein
navi montieren und zu sagen das bestimmt
die chance für eine für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht im dezember besser gewesen
wäre über erwartungen verknüpfen aber
als die diskussion wird genau aber herr
bremer sie müssen ja auch sagen wir
haben in der ampelkoalition diese
debatte wie wir die korona handeln und
die ganzen maßnahmen verändert haben die
ins parlament geholt vorwurfsvoll
bundesregierung gemacht habe das
parlament geholten das breit diskutiert
und ich finde es auch noch stärker zu
sagen ist der kanzler sagt er ist in so
einer frage mit diskutant und die
abgeordneten als gewählte volksvertreter
finden sich in gruppen zusammen mit
verschiedenen lösungen verschiedenen
ansätzen und diskutieren das in der
herzkammer der demokratie an der stelle
als repräsentative vertreter der
bevölkerung das finde ich eine riesige
stärke dieses verfahrens das ist nicht
von einer regierungskommission
vorgenommen das gehe sehr kritisiert
dass damals das nicht als
regierungsvorlage gemacht worden ist er
finde ich es auch schnee von gestern
mich stört an der argumentation von frau
hat folgendes damals hätte man eine
mehrheit gekriegt weil ja immer noch die
data variante da war bionicon nicht
nennen das heißt für mich im
umkehrschluss wir reden wieder
übernehmen pflicht wenn wir eine ganz
gefährliche mutation haben nur wenn die
mutationen da ist dann ist jede
impfpflicht zu spät aber wir haben noch
einen vorschlag gemacht der genauen
beiden lösungen vorsieht die einmal ganz
jetzt den vorschlag beschreiben den die
union wahrgenommen die zuschauer dies
vielleicht nicht mit lob geht darum dass
wir jetzt schon die voraussetzungen
schaffen für eine impfpflicht
aber auch mit mit einem im free gestern
alles vorplanen dass wenn es wirklich
wir wissen ja nicht was im herbst kommt
und ich muss ihnen doch nicht sagen
grundrechtseingriff auf vorrat ist
nunmal verfassungsrechtlich nicht
möglich wenn ich absolut deutlich
stärkere durch ein dorf der gleichen
auffassung wenn wir wieder eine delta
oder eine ähnlich starke variante haben
die wieder zu schweren verläufen führt
die zur überlastung der kliniken führen
und wir einen wirksamen impfstoff haben
dann kann diese endlich schafft
geschalten werden natürlich durch einen
nochmaligen bundestagsbeschluss
amerikanischen mehr sich alle menschen
dann geimpft ist diese neue welle von
aber die brauchen eine datengrundlage
dass dies unmöglich zu sagen dass dieser
grundrechtseingriff verhältnismäßig
geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig im engen sinn also
angemessen ist im hinblick auf den
legitimen zweck
und recht sein das ist ein grundrecht
der gesetzgeber hat leben und gesundheit
zu schützen und nicht im vordergrund die
geschäfte und die gastwirtschaften und
das ist natürlich ist sie auch gehen und
alle jeden alters werden in karlsruhe
sind gescheitert herr buschmann ist der
baum darf ich ihnen noch eine frage
stellen ich sitze jetzt neben ihnen und
ich kannte es eben sehr bewegend wo sie
gesagt haben sie sind fast 90 und
natürlich gehören sie zur risikogruppe
ich bin gebucht hat aber ich kann sie
doch genauso anstecken können sie sich
denn überhaupt neben mir sitzen sicher
fühlen weil ich den ich kann den jungs
ja auch übertragen obwohl ich gewusst
ich möchte mich darin stecken was
verstehen sie wollen dass ich eigentlich
immer zu den stücken auch nicht
irgendwer können sie
hätte es denn das was ist das für eine
einschränkung dass man in bestimmten
situationen eine maske trägt die dass
der das oft stößt auf große akzeptanz
jeder gehabt weil es ja in ihrer und
vielleicht die koalition will sitzen
nicht mehr aber wir noch nichts gegen
die masken pflicht aber die impfpflicht
ist das verfassungsrechtliche probleme
die im flur land ist ja das müssen wir
mal verschiedene probleme sprechen jetzt
einfach die fassung die these erinnerung
nach verfassungsrecht einfach und wurden
auch gelernter jurist und zwar mit
beiden ex amt dann freue ich mich jetzt
auf die these von fräulein hat weil ich
glaube das könnte jetzt ein spannender
kampf werden zwischen den beiden
juristen